[Musique]
Quoi
Je serai sans l'ombre de ton
[Musique]
l'aube quand tu m'as perdu comme hier
Tu me dis ce que je serai pour toi
je ne dis qu'une seule façon de
vivre ce que nous devons
ça arrive, dis-moi ce que tu
dis que je pars avec douleur sans la fleur de ta
alle-moi
J'irai avec le pardon sans le don de ton
[Musique]
œillet quand
C'est à ce moment-là que tu as appris de moi quoi
Je sais, je ne me souviens même pas de la façon dont je t'ai parlé, dis-moi
toi et quand c'était comment
Je suis allé à côté de toi
oui, je ne me souviens même pas quand je t'ai vu, dis-moi
et comment j'étais, je pars avec douleur sans la fleur
de toi
Je repartirai avec plaisir avec le pardon sans le don de
toi
Je l'ai réussi quand
C'est à ce moment-là que tu as appris de moi quoi
Je sais que je ne me souviens même pas comment je t'ai parlé, dis-moi Elo
toi et quand
c'était je pars
conar la fleur
à
Pardonne-moi sans le cadeau de ton
clé qui
Je serai sans l'ombre de ton
[Musique]
l'aube quand tu m'as perdu comme hier
Tu me dis quoi
Je serai un homme de
j'ai vécu tout ce qui nous concerne
ça arrive, dis-moi, tu dis quoi
[Musique]
a donné
h